e aí a gente regional tudo bom você se
não tiver aqui então o que fazemos o seu
pai também tomar lanche
é bom estar lá para cá da sic sintáxi
cana voltou a acertar e op collor é
desatualizada alertam chega no final 90
graças a glote muito obrigado por ter
conseguido o texto consegui chegar até
aqui mas o assunto esse vídeo não é
iguaçu desse vídeo é mais uma felicidade
que quem proporcionou vocês o dia de seu
filho vi comemorando 40 milhões de
visualizações e hoje nós vamos comemorar
900 mil inscritos num amigo não visse
duas mil pessoas a cada 8 já contra o
magnata num maracanã lotado de pessoas é
estourado uma 90.000 cara nós temos que
gostou cara nós temos 900 mil pessoas
imagina imagina lei 9 60 mil pessoas
agora imagina 9 60 mil pessoas tudo
encaminhado junto de nomes entre milton
leite de bosta 2 é merda pra cá com 895
mil um número muito grande eu falei que
não tinha feito aquela promessa de só
cortar o cabelo com 200 mil inscritos e
fiz e agora estou com a meta de só
cortar meu cabelo com um milhão e
estamos chegando lá é muito obrigado
você fez parte disso eu queria já pedi
que você desce aquele gostei só você que
está me acompanhando que todo o vídeo da
gostei é que as pessoas que falam assim
nem assiste já tem gostei por família de
maio pela confiança confiança do neto
quando eu fiz 800 mil inscritos falei
gente vamos lá no twitter e vamos fazer
e as tags wilson união diz que foi quase
primeiro pois é pois hoje a gente vai
botar a hashtag o resto é ruim de som
900 mil inscritos e assunto quero muito
que isso porque quando você fala o insta
os absolverá tegra fala que é omisso vai
precisar de um riacho no canal se
inscreve e vai chegar mais rápido em um
escritório é você me ajudando a gente
vai chegar a 1 milhão de inscritos
quando eu fizer um milhão de inscritos
vai ser ouvido mais é que [ __ ] doido mas
seu vídeo mais basta ter plugues visa
débito no crédito daiane dos santos por
diego hypólito máximo power que você já
viu na vida
galera a caminhada é duro tem aquela
pessoa que fala não vai dar certo aquela
pessoa que joga pra mim você olha a
gente sempre dá um jeito nas coisas que
tá brincando nessa taxa de inscrição a
gente sempre dá um jeito nas coisas
[ __ ] muita gente não dá certo não sei o
que a gente tá aqui a gente conseguiu
mostrar meu amigo sem saber 900 mil
inscritos tentar san pio xii um pouco o
carro daqui a muito obrigado a você que
fez parte disso se você faz parte disso
comenta aqui embaixo e desejando boa
sorte o que eu já fiz que é prender
anunciar onde todas pepe loja naquele 15
maroto é posta e ta meun e tá aí já que
aproveitar e mandar parabéns aí na neve
que está fazendo 18 anos hoje 18 na data
especial mpe ou aqui pelo twitter deu só
que foi bem na hora eu estava gravando
valeu e você me segue no twitter eu
também poderia estar aqui neste momento
não me saiu o primeiro na descrição do
vídeo só clicar em seguida você vai ver
tudo valeu